the grain trade center in vienna was the
17th urban bombing in four weeks blamed
on nod terrorists
and security commission remains in close
session tonight following nod terrorist
actions in slovenia
at least your mother tipped well
[Music]
harsh
unforgiving
new tiberium harvesting methods
instituted by the brotherhood of nod
increase profitability by 49 percent
not tiberium holdings now account for
almost half of the world's known supply
giving the quasi-terrorist group
incredible leverage in the london gold
exchange on the domestic side
[Music]
[Music]
cover of tiberium ignored reporters at
hong kong second world tiberium economic
impact summit mobius is expected to
refute charges from the scientific
community that tiberium might be
dangerous
[Music]
as the gdi forces take off in another
non-assault the free world holds its
press
this is greg burdette wwn somewhere in
the mediterranean
matrix
global defense initiative selected are
you picking this up
good i know you need more deep
background but we're up against it
non-forces have fortified this beachhead
at x-16 y-42 intelligence is still
coming in so we can't tell you a lot but
we found a [ __ ] in their armor
commander carter can sneak you in some
backup forces on shore right here you
may get some artillery support from his
gunboats but this is mostly grunt work
permission is simple
knock out all fortifications eliminate
all nod troops and establish a beachhead
by building your base
good luck
yes
reinforcements
[Music]
[Music]
instruction complete
new
instruction complete
yes
accomplished
[Music]
immediately